people of the internet retro rack and
tour here and welcome back to harry
potter and the chamber of secrets now
guys we are picking up
right where we left off from last time
we just rescued neville
from behind the tapestry we had to go
out find the severing charm
which was in the herbology greenhouse
but first we had to find the
horror clump book we took care of that
we got neville
and now we are ready to end our day
and see what the next day brings at
hogwarts so let's go ahead and hit end
day here ah yes
time for the point total update let's
see how we're doing it gryffindor
oh hufflepuff just caught up only down
by one point right now
ravenclaw 79 and slytherin
also 79 wow a very close race
i'm not really sure if i did something
wrong why
i didn't go up at all as gryffindor but
hey
you know what we're just gonna just
gotta run with it
ah the early morning music
of another day at hogwarts let's go
ahead and pull out i remember all
see if it has anything listed on it no
to do at all so far so looks like right
now we're just going to head downstairs
and see if we're presented with any
tasks here
yep right away we've got first thing is
defense against the dark hearts harry
with guild wars yes let's do it let's do
it
me neither i'll meet you on the third
floor outside the defense against the
dark arts class
third floor got it hermione third floor
defense gets the dark arts
now another thing is i think that i am
really close let's check my total number
of
yeah i've got 87 beans right now so
before we reach nightfall on this day
i really want to try and make sure that
i get 100.
now i did find that potions kit bag so
now it looks like a gryffindor merit
badge has been lost
dropped while wandering around the grand
staircase if found please return to this
notice board okay
and of course we get a wizard card very
nice for returning the other item the
potions bag number 45
dunbar oglethorpe dunbar oglethorpe 1968
to present
chief of quabble which stands for the
quidditch union for the administration
and betterment of the british league
and its endeavors interesting looking
guy right there
kind of gives me some uh heisenberg
vibes
anybody anybody breaking bad
all right moving on from that one i i
wish they would go into a little more
detail
some of them do but then a couple of
them are just pretty basic like that
let's see if there's anything behind
here now
we already got neville from out behind
anybody bought beans because we could
use some
for sure
nope not seeing anything uh and we can't
go in there right now
because or we can but we can't visit
fred and george's
by the way guys if you are checking out
one of my videos for the first time
i want to thank you so much for watching
and let you know that i'm just
a dad who loves games and the stories
they tell we post videos every week here
on youtube
including quite a few videos on the
upcoming hogwarts legacy
well i say upcoming 2022
so hopefully we'll get more information
on that one soon whoops sorry did not
mean to do that
also i have some uh animal crossing
videos up on the channel as well as a
started a returnal let's play on the ps5
which i'm having a lot of fun with so
far now if you guys have any other
suggestions for games you'd like to see
me play
obviously we're gonna make our way
through all the harry potter games
but if you have any other suggestions be
sure and let me know down in the
comments below i'd love to hear from you
guys
so right now it looks like the only
thing we have to do
is go to defense against the dark arts
now i'm just going to hop
in here just kind of check make sure
there's no obvious place
for some birdie bot beans to be hiding
since i do just need
oh come on no birdy bop beans in the
suits of armor
oh right here i wonder why it doesn't
give any on the first
all right 95
oh that one it took three times and then
it just gave one
i think that's what happens when you've
already accessed
that item once before to get birdie bot
beans
see let's see if this one does the same
thing nope out and did it first try
all right so we are in 98 we need two
more beans
now getting the beans isn't gonna be a
problem it's gonna be
actually keeping the beans not getting
hit by something
that is going to be the problem all
right let's make our way down i think
third floor is where they said yep
defense against the dark guards
okay so we've got two doors here i
wonder if it matters which one we go
through
let's see now see like right here the
camera come on
oh wait this wasn't here before
i don't remember this being here because
unless i totally missed it which is
possible
you guys know i've done that before
number 98 dymphna firmage now this one
right here
it looks like yeah i've got a duplicate
of that card
so i know one of you who watches the
videos pretty regularly wario land gold
pyramid pointed out that in the first
harry potter game you actually can't
get duplicates at least in the pc
version however it looks like here for
chamber of secrets that you
can indeed get duplicates because it
looks like they're kind of stacked right
there unless it's
slightly different somehow what would be
the point of giving you a duplicate
maybe i can sell it later on i don't
know i'm trying to remember so
we'll read it again though
dymphnafirmage1612 to 1698 famously
abducted by pixies while oh i remember
reading this one
while on vacation in cornwall and lived
in mortal dread of them thereafter
filed to persuade the ministry of magic
to have all pixies
humanely destroyed okay well i mean if
it's if it's done humanely
right oh that's good stuff
okay so yeah i do not remember that
chest being there and i definitely went
in here on a previous night
so that means that things can get added
and changed as we go along
i think was that hermione waiting right
there yeah it is okay hermione before we
talk
i just wanna i just wanna round it out
and get that 100th birdie bot bean right
there
all right let's do this is he in here
classroom 3c defense against
the dark odds all right there he is oh
lockhart and snape this must be the
dueling lesson
right from the get-go here can everyone
see me can you all hear me
excellent this time i shall be teaching
dueling
let me introduce you to my assistant
here we go snape
now potter if you'd like to come forward
the experiment spell challenge is
through here
oh just me what you have to do is to
find the expelliarmus spell book
somewhere beyond the portrait once you
have the spell book in your possession
the expelliarmus spell will be yours to
use as you see fit
something tells me the the expelliarmus
spell it might be a little bit important
harry
just a little
jesus is creepy oh my goodness
i wasn't expecting that
lumos lumos come on harry
i don't know what you guys think you all
think expellormis might be useful to
harry at some point
maybe you know somewhere down the line
dude the music
the foreboding
okay for pindo panel over there and over
there
whoa defendo
see i told you man
i'll miss that one
what am i supposed to do
oh my goodness it's lighting up pink
like i'm supposed to hit it with defendo
but
okay all right flapindo it is
dude i'm trying to lock on too
about to lose all the beans right here
in this room man
right here in this room no give it back
okay let me go ahead and hit this one
watch there's gonna be more it's just
gonna be more
no okay i really
what am i doing wrong dodge it okay
dodge it dodge it they're lighting up
pink it's gotta be defendo
am i not holding it down long enough
like is that is that the problem
are you serious my health bar guys
okay we gotta read defense against i
mean that's all they give us dude
nothing
oh no
all right this time i think i just have
to wait and like time it like right when
it's about
to hit me nope
[Music]
are you serious
we've only lost four beans so far
wait lupino actually connected with it
but
oh that's right that wiggin weld potion
it just saved me so we're not dead
but i mean i i still have no idea how to
combat these things
if i wasn't losing beans left and right
i would just
stand there spamming defendo
what dude
[Music]
no
like it clearly wants me
[Music]
what i just hit that one with
okay i can't hit them with defendo at
all like i have no idea
what's going on with defendo
we're gonna die not once but twice
like lock on harry dude
okay got that one got that one
and then more just more just come out
they just
just more spawn
did my beans reset please tell me my
beans reset
they don't reset dude cutthroat man okay
we're only gonna do one at a time
at least that will help us focus on just
one
like the fact that they light up pink
tells me that
okay you have to wait until after they
come at you but then they just
if you hit them with flupino they just
they just come back
so one of two things you have to
get rid of all of them very quickly with
flupindo
or there's a way that i just haven't
figured out yet that you have to get
them with
it's got to be defendo guys it's gotta
be
like i don't even see the spell though
you see that
like i know defendo has a different
effect then
[Music]
volpindo does
okay like that just did not connect
right there
just straight up didn't connect
okay let's reassess here we've got
flopindo
on the indicator maybe we just need to
keep it simple
and just go one at a time just like have
one attack me then run back
and fire for pindo at it see another one
comes out though
run back fire for pindo run back run
back there's two coming at me
let's see if they ever just stop
are we good now are we good
man what's with that pink highlight
though
come on man throwing me off like that
all right so wait for him to charge me
there we go see like the fact that they
just immediately come back i thought oh
i'm doing something wrong clearly
yeah yeah come after me another one
another one
and another another
gotcha and you you gonna be the last one
boom all right something better happen
now
okay i think this is the way i'm
supposed to go
all right so then i also want to check
out what's over here though
because there better be a reason there
better be a reason that they had one of
these on both sides
other than just trying to keep me
occupied
which if so it worked
yeah there we go was about to say there
better be
something special or secret back here
okay now the question though is this yes
we definitely need another wig and weld
potion since we already used the last
one
nice all your vials are now full all
right so now we got to build back up our
birdie bop beans though
unfortunately let's see what do we drop
down to 80 something
75 75
come on man come on man
all right well i guess that was worth it
to walk over this side get the wig and
well potion dude look at the graphics
right now though man
gamecube this looks really good
got those reflections on the floor down
there
look at that look at that very nice
you guys hear that
something spinning very fast very very
fast
oh no oh
no we we had enough trouble with the
tiny little spikes i don't know how i
feel about these
massive spikes now all right clearly
defendo
like see normally the pink would mean
all right come here you can i pick you
up now
i wonder where i'm supposed to throw him
is there a cage in the room i'll just
toss him down there get him out of the
way
hopefully that works
oh he's still down there is he getting
around oh he's totally running after me
come on pick him up toss him overboard
come on pick him up the other one's
going to be up here oh here he comes
dude look at him
it's gonna be three this time
no not three but still come on we gotta
hurry harry
get him off
be golden i feel ya i feel ya
you don't have a cage to throw them in
so we just have to chuck them off the
side right now all right nothing back
there
and was it one final defender probably
come on
uh whoa oh that is so sneaky man
i was just gonna run through the door
then i was like you know what look
there's a chest right there
no oh that little punk i don't even care
about the beans dude imagine if he
knocked me completely off
go away are you for real
just just grab the chest harry just grab
it
pumpkin or uh cauldron cake okay
out of my way
this little pests okay
so we got that and then we got the door
over here
defendo right there are you serious man
are you serious more of these little
dudes
is that really as fast as you can run
harry oh dude this is kind of dark right
here
i'm sure he's fine right i mean
he's fine it's totally fine dude oh no
more
come on give him up
harry run faster
all right pick him up and
chuck him overboard i think i just heard
another one man
are you for real they just keep coming
all right get through there get through
there
oh no not these guys
as if we hadn't lost enough beans
already
all right at least we're getting some
health that's good we definitely need it
definitely need the health man look at
this area
i can't get over the music just how like
how dark and bleak it is
the echo of the you can just feel how
massive this
this cavern area is okay wait wait wait
wait wait a second no i'm shooting him
don't make me lock on every time all
right can i just hop up there
good good
what a punk can i just like sneak by
this guy
yeah see that's what i was trying
we should have never tried to get 100
birdy bot beans guys
not before this not before this area
this was
not the time to do it
i think what you're gonna have to do is
basically like after
no no no we can weld potion for
the win no
that stream of fire goes so much further
than i expect it to go
all right let's see i was ready for it
that time
no i thought it stopped when i blasted
him
so wait what's the point of me what's
the point of me blasting him at all
dude this is really bad we've lost so
much health
so many beans we're gonna be we're gonna
be down to zero beans pretty soon
yeah 39. we started this area with
100 beans a nice even 100.
now here we are at 39.
okay oh that's that other room nice now
it's gonna block the fire
or just lower that that works too
you mean you're not gonna let me explore
up there a little bit more first i guess
i should have waited before
casting defendo this kind of looks like
it might be a hidden doorway
no okay how about over here nope
all right you know what
okay this is just stairs i can run down
here
just making sure you know what i should
do i should go and refresh that wig and
weld potion man
especially since i'm already super low
on health again
yeah this is the right way pretty sure
it's the right way
there it is i need to buy another
vial too fred george have a lot of good
stuff for sale that it's going to be
pretty useful an extra potion vial is
one of them
see i barely died at all in the first
harry potter game the one on pc
but this one man i think this is the
first time we've died in the let's play
it's tonight
and it's not been once it's been several
deaths
but honestly it's when i i couldn't
figure something out it wasn't like it
was particularly
mechanically difficult you know what i
mean it's just
what exactly you're supposed to do all
right this has got to be expelliarmus
right
and we're going to have to map that to
one of our our three buttons
because we have more than three spells
now chapter five
mastering wizard dueling reflects an
opponent's spell
back at them okay so book readers and
even movie fans will know that this is
not
how expelliarmus really works so the way
that they have it working here is it
reflects an opponent's spell back at
them in reality this would be more
similar to like protego
let's see how they word it here as we go
along the expelliarmus dueling charm
lies at the heart of a good dueling
technique
expelliarmus allows the duelist to
rebound an opponent's spell in the hope
that the rebounded spell
will strike the opponent and leave him
or her vulnerable to further attack yeah
they should have used protago that's not
expelliarmus at all but it's okay you
know
we'll go with it yeah so
it's definitely more like a shielding
charm in this game to deflect a spell
back
oh and they're gonna put it to the test
right away i'm really glad we refreshed
that wiggin weld potion man
all right so let's wait that's not the
right spot i need to press
and let's put it on
gosh i don't know actually because i
feel like we're using defindo a lot too
right now
lumos i don't know dude we'll just do
this for now
oh i held it too soon okay
wait what
oh my goodness
[Music]
i don't care getting my beans back
what why is it not working
okay that's not even close to me come on
hit me
there we go there we go
ocarina of time right now man
ocarina of time vibes
there we go oh you're not done yet you
want to go again you want wanna go again
okay okay one more
i'm gonna shoot that one off to the side
all right all right
what it just didn't react it didn't work
i pressed the button
come on get that bean bag i want the
beans i want all the beans
back give them to me all right now we're
ready
now we're ready
oh i thought he was totally gonna block
that time surprised
he didn't block twice on that one
i do like the mechanic though i i think
we've seen a
uh in the trailer we see a similar
moment with what looks to be protego in
hogwarts legacy
okay wait what
can i just climb up here maybe oh yeah
there we go
wait is there anything on the other side
of the room just kind of this
random cauldron not even a cauldron hold
on hold on
hold on a second
oh you can't hop up there about here can
i hop up here
oh come on harry you could totally make
that
because that would be like a great place
to hide a hidden path you know
same for there yeah well let me hop up
there yeah he can make this
he can jump up there seems reasonable
all right let's move on you know they're
going to keep testing us with the uh
i'm going to want to call it protego but
for sake of continuity with the game
we'll just call it expelliarmus
oh yeah here it comes here comes we're
definitely gonna have to use it
but who is it gonna be it's gonna be
malfoy
i bet it's malfoy dude malfoy's gonna
come strolling down here
no no okay ooh snape's waiting for us
there's lockhart well done potter
40 points for griffin we needed some
points lockhart thank you to use the
expelliar spell you've just acquired
in a real duel yeah let's go
over here let's see what you can make of
the famous
potter let's go first duelist to gain
five points
wins the dew very well then one's at the
ready
scared potter count to three
scared potter you you one
shoe three all right malfoy let's dance
bro
okay we'll trade it trade it trade it
oh malfoy is pretty quick dude
that should have totally hit him
that should totally not have hit me
oh yeah right on your bottom malfoy
right on his backside
oh yeah there we go three to one we got
this potter
see like that that mechanic should not
be in where it hits you when
when it's on the ground beside you
thank you oh my goodness
[ __ ]
[Music]
why didn't you tell us i'm a what
a parcel mouth you can talk to snakes
so does it matter it matters harry
because being able to talk to oh there's
a big chest right there
was famous for that's why the symbol oh
it's an aloha chest now the whole
school's going to think you're his great
great great great grandson or something
but i'm not you'll find that hard
about a thousand years ago for all we
know you could be
anyway we've got quidditch practice next
oh quidditch practice
i'll meet you in the entrance hall harry
let's go
all right before we do that though uh
let's get some birdy bop beans man
and by some i mean like 60.
we've we've got to replenish all those
birdie bop beans that we lost man that
was
so bad that was brutal wait where'd that
chest go oh it's up there at the front
of the room
yeah we're definitely gonna need to get
alohomora
can i not blast that skull up there
nothing in the desks oh
man it's usually a good place to find
the birdie bot beans
or to find something anyway it doesn't
have to be beans
oh look at these pictures look at that
there's lockhart
on top of a troll
here's looking out the window looks like
mcgonagall right there
i guess he i guess he's a fan of
mcgonagall or something
i'm surprised it's not just all lock
cart in here there's one with him
yep there he is of course oh him
painting himself
looking at himself in a mirror is that a
mirror
it's not clearly not a mirror but
yeah he's like making his own portrait
of himself
some random witch right here
lockhart again and let's see his
lockhart up there too
yeah there's one of them there at the
top right as well
let's see oh there's like what how many
more over here of him
there's that one right there of same one
of mcgonagall again
oh man nothing else in here
so we need like the scourge spell
scurgify
to get that one open and then we need
aloha mora
on the other one can't get through there
all right fine fine fine fine
oh dude that's pretty cool the bones up
there up top
let's see if we can get some more beans
out of these now
oh yes lots of beans there big time big
time
because i don't think i will lose beans
at quidditch practice
although it's possible it is totally
possible see what's in here
oh another wizard card
[Applause]
number 57 gifford olliton
gifford allerton 1390 to 1441
famous giant slayer killed the giant
hingist of upper barton
well he looks pretty strong okay
all right any more birdie bop beans
oh okay how about in here
nope all right fine into the grand
staircase
yes very bop beans
we need lots of birdy bop beans are you
not gonna let me get there we go thank
you
oh no come on move i need that bean
thank you
oh yeah we're gonna be able to get a lot
of beans just in this little area alone
[Music]
okay three
four five six okay not six
yes yes more beans
hello there i think that ginny weasley
really likes you harry
oh really is that so
yeah this is dumbledore's office can't
get in there oh come on albus not gonna
let me stop by for a little chat
okay this is a classroom oh is there a
chess back here
dude see they just keep sneaking these
in because we have definitely went
through this room before
i guess i'm gonna need a check every day
number 73
mopsus wow ancient greek
mopsis soothsayer who vanquished the
seer
calcus or calchus in a contest of their
powers
wow that's pretty cool
man i hope hogwarts legacy just has like
a ton of collectibles you know
oh this is what i'm supposed to do with
the desks
you guys were probably screaming it when
i was in lockhart's
classroom i mean come on wouldn't
flopindo realistically wouldn't
would it not work
if i can open up the desk this easily
come on fulpindo should totally have
worked you guys know
you guys know i'm right
blueberry all right
and we already got that chest anything
over there
look a rabbit out of a hat okay let's
head back this way
all right dumbledore's office oh my
goodness it resets
wow that's pretty cool i guess this
whole hallway resets
on the birdie bot beans
because i feel like not all of them
reset
that quickly because i mean i was just
in here now like that one only had
one in there okay two fine
two whatever
how about this one this one reset yes it
did
already back up to 82.
all right let's check our remember i'll
see if we have anything
besides quidditch practice okay that's
it
all right and we are back in the great
hall now we need to look for that
gryffindor
uh crest there was that someone who lost
it they said
down here in the i think they set down
here right
now see look at all these new chests but
we've got to learn we've got to learn
more spells
this one what is that oh that's going to
be incendio
i don't think i have incendio yet do i
no
i know incendio but we do have defendo
if we come across
any of those curtains remember
okay maybe it's in this area where that
little
about right in here somewhere oh maybe
down here
locked nope not through there
it was like that little uh gryffindor
badge or something
somebody was missing
and i thought they said like the
entrance hall area
okay that's locked another chest over
there keep
out what in the world get through there
what in the world
all right we've got that one's locked
okay wait maybe i just need to run over
here to this side
[Music]
nothing i oh this one's actually open
though
oh is that another alohomora chest it is
dude
how about you oh gameboy advance link
not activated that's locked
i totally forgot about that
functionality man
[Music]
if any of you remember connecting the
gamecube version
to the gameboy advance let me know in
the comments below and let me know what
the functionality was
of course i could look it up of course i
could just look it up and google it but
i want to hear from you guys if
if you specifically remember it and have
a story about it that those are the best
man when
people actually remember doing i'm
pretty sure that i did
but i can't fully remember the
functionality i think was it was it like
a marauder's map or something maybe
wait what's the deal with that door he
can't even try to open it
all right there's ron he's ready for
quidditch practice
can i go in the great hall no darn it
wait why is ron going to quidditch
practice he didn't play in the second
year he didn't play in year two
okay fine you can go ron let's go dude
hello harry
let's go outside to the quidditch
stadium
okay if i remember right quidditch
stadium is this way
yeah there we go there's ronnie's
waiting for me i'm just gonna go on in
listen up you lot we're going to make
sure we win the quidditch cup this year
and the way we're going to do that
first a quick recap of what we learned
last year you tell them
over here potter
now watch carefully okay i can't
remember what my controls were
through each ring but i remember it felt
very weird
so i might need to to do the inverse
uh i don't know i mean that that
actually feels that actually feels what
i expected
okay
now you're going faster you'll see the
magical charge in your broom has
increased too
you see this in the trail the broom is
leaving in the air behind you
perfect
the magical charge in your brain is at
maximum you can now get that extra boost
of speed
i'll press y for the boost
oh whoa
super fast or it will reduce the magical
charge
[Music]
my goodness oh my goodness we're going
super fast we're like right behind the
snitch
no no you're close enough
if you boost now you'll have a chance of
grabbing it okay
oh wait sharp turn sharp turn
and we have totally lost the snitch doll
harry
[Music]
dude how do we oh my goodness how do we
avoid those
am i supposed to like bob and weave bob
and weave
okay we got the boost wait why is it not
boosting oh you have to push
you have to push a and y at the same
time that's a little
it's a little difficult actually
gamecube controller makes that a little
more
possible though and that
sharp turn right there yeah i'm not
going to use the boost yet because i
want to wait until it's actually
not like over here going making all
these crazy twists and turns
hey wait for it come on head back there
we go right there
[Applause]
there we go good job harry
only one crash not bad not bad
is that it we get to do it again okay
you know the score
one opposing seeker two bludgers and two
opposing beaters to contend with
all you have to do is catch the snitch
oh we gotta do it again okay oh wait is
this the actual game
i'm so confused what's happening wood
i think it's just another practice i
don't see any other opponent
players or any gryffindor players for
that matter
what's this meter at the bottom here is
that just showing like how close i am to
the snitch
and then i think if i remember right
when we play another team
they'll be on the bottom part so i can
see how close their seeker is as well
all right we have the boost ready but
again like i'm not gonna activate boost
when i'm over here and
doing all these twists and turns
it's almost the exact same path that it
followed last time
there we go
oh come on harry oh what
i'm just spamming i'm gonna be honest
with you
oh no there you go okay good good good i
think it was just about to fly away
if i didn't get it that time
[Applause]
sounded like it was speeding up a little
bit superb performance harry
you receive an a plus and because of
that excellent performance harry here's
a brand new nimbus 2012 wait
we're getting graded to fly anywhere
around the grounds but anywhere around
the house
come back and see me here at any time of
the day he said on a plus right yeah
improve my quidditch time what are you
talking about wood what are you talking
about mim
hello there hermione uh what's wrong
what's the matter
malfoy showed up while you were
practicing in the quidditch stadium
he's been made seeker after his dad
brought his way onto the team with a
whole set
of nimbus 2001's hermione said something
about it and he called her a filthy mud
blood
oh what dang ron you just come out and
say it like that
a disgusting name for someone who was
born
come on dude there are some wizards like
malfoy's family who think they're better
than everyone else
anyway it's a horrible thing to say if
it hadn't been for hagrid showing up i'd
have cursed him
he's not worth the trouble i suppose
you're right
are we not gonna get the slugs do we not
get eat slugs
in in the game
[Music]
that was chamber seekers right i'm
pretty sure it was
yeah because he it was after he called
her a mudblood
okay end of day man all right guys uh i
think that's going to be a good stopping
point for this one we
learned expelliarmus which is really
more like protego in defense against the
dark arts and we had our quidditch
practice
we're ready for the end of the day so uh
next time we'll be ready to start the
evening hours and hopefully we'll be
able to run up and
round up enough birdy bop beans to make
some big time purchases from fred and
george
thank y'all so much for watching i'll
talk to you all again soon